walk us through that moment what
happened actually uh me personally in
the moment I thought I had messed up
horribly we reviewed the footage and my
aim was on point it was actually the O's
an equipment malfunction her laser dot
was actually on the target I thought she
had missed two and then we looked and
the notch on the arrow at the back had
broken so I really kind of lucky the
string if she had just missed it
actually would have gone probably
through my neck but because the play had
slipped it kind of came at an angle with
less power so lucky but unlucky yeah you
know what was that initial thought what
was going through your guys's head when
the Happ initial thought I wasn't sure
what happened I knew I had been hit by
it I want to make sure I wasn't on fire
because that's where a lot of it hit was
that wick that hit me and then you know
I wanted to make sure amber was okay you
know she felt really bad about it but we
weren't sure what happened until we saw
the footage the actual stunt was
actually the arrow was supposed to go
down the tube in his esophagus and it
actually shoots pyrotechnics out of it
if it goes right it's an amazing amazing
stunt that's never been done in the
entire world you guys think you'll ever
get a chance to do it again would you
that first thing we're going to do is
get back on that and run it again so
we're not afraid of it will be posting
footage of it working properly that's
the